au départ il y avait une belle chiasse
on la voit du groupe de 6 ans formé avec
son frère il ya maintenant hubert
rebaptisé le noir qui chante en solo et
en français je suis prêt je suis du bar
à travers de six ans
je suis hubbard dans ma vie c'est pas
donc je sais je sais être quelqu'un qui
fait de la muse et puis il y a eu la
roma ce spectacle au cercle de mon
groupe
puis à l'aimer de seasons finalement en
alain descend d'un auto allaitent et
j'ai rencontré la loge fiancée on nous
regarde sont croisés concis plus lâcher
le couple travailler chacun de son côté
elle sur un romain lui sur un disque
mais tous les deux raconter une histoire
qui leur ressemble
tout a pris un sens lui le concept de
son album qui mon histoire de mon âge
qui sont racontées la même chose
finalement puis c'est vraiment histoire
d'émancipation d'amour puis de
rencontrer celui qui était destinée
commune un début semblables je dirais
qu'on a décidé à voir comme la main une
fin
darlene c'est aussi le portrait d'une
génération sans exclure non plus une
seule roue les jeunes de notre âge ici
qui vivent peut-être la même genre de
choses qui connaissent en avons parlé à
châteauguay où je sais pas où ailleurs
dans le monde
[Musique]
les chansons du verre sont écrites comme
autant de lettres à darlene
je pense que je les écris aussi un peu
pour pour darlene puis pour noémie vie
un peu pauvre j'ai connu quand même
beaucoup de filles dans ma vie je me
suis mieux entendre que les filles en
général à l'image de leurs personnages
hubert henno et me revendique le droit
d'être qu'ils sont ou de se réinventer
en dehors des carcans et a dit ici
mélanie boissonneault radio canada
montréal
[Musique]